[Applause]
music the international language the
food of love it soothes the Savage Beast
our brains recognize and react to music
before we're even born it can affect our
moods and our senses in way scientists
are only beginning to discover and
anything can turn into music
anything can turn into music
anything can turn into music say it with
me anything can turn into music anything
can turn into music
[Applause]
how can a simple sentence become music
it's based on a phenomenon called the
speech to song illusion after repeating
the phrase a few times we stop paying
attention to the meaning of the words
and our brains focus on the melody and
rhythm
it's all about music with Jack Black on
this episode
[Applause]
[Music]
Jack being known
as an award-winning comedic actor that's
just one thing right okay everybody
knows that but you're also a
grammy-winning metal musician with your
power Duo tenacious me
right
people that's right don't forget that
guys
today we are exploring the relationship
between our brains and music Jack how do
you think your favorite music affects
you brain wise well a man puts you in a
Zone yeah I use it as a tool to psych up
or to wind down uh you know I can't
imagine my life without music in it I
definitely wouldn't be where I am today
without it that's true and uh music I
think has the power to save the world
I'll take it
I'll take it
we're just going to do a lot of this
today
no reason not to
we all know people respond to different
music but did you know we actually hear
it differently as well we're going to do
a little experiment you will be building
a giant blue face over here and it's uh
based on your answers to a series of
musical questions in this game we're
exploring the tritone paradox
an auditory illusion that's perceived in
different ways by different people our
players are going to hear several pairs
of tones like this one
if they hear the tones Rising they'll
add one kind of item to their face if
they hear the tones falling
they'll add a different kind of item at
the end we'll check out the faces to see
exactly who heard what
so now we're going to elicit the help of
your Tenacious D co-star Kyle
[Applause]
in the mirror
we have to build blue faces all right
so Kyle you're going to be building some
faces here all right uh we're also
enlisting the help of two audience
volunteers who are not professional
musicians so Gentlemen please take your
places and you at home keep track of how
you hear these tones here we go here we
go here we go
spin your faces
listen
to these tones
okay if those tones sounded like they
were rising to you put the eyeballs on
your face if the tone sounded like they
were falling put on your glasses
[Music]
now listen
to the next set of tones
[Music]
if they're Rising add the blonde
mustache if they're falling add the
black one
here are the next two tones listen very
carefully
okay falling add the open mouth Rising
add the bright red lips
okay okay
and finally our last pair of tones
if they're Rising add the brown hair if
they're falling add the top hat
and she blaps okay here we go Jack Kyle
come on over here to me please and thank
you to our volunteers thank you guys
all right so everybody just heard the
same four sets of musical tones so let's
turn the faces please
oh
okay
Jack and Kyle I could tell from the
mustaches that you two heard those tones
differently so Jack you heard it falling
and Kyle you heard it Rising so let's
listen to that particular tone one more
time audience
foreign
[Music]
that it's falling
[Music]
and who agrees with Kyle that it's
rising
[Applause]
real Ah that's fascinating how'd this
happen
this experiment is based on a phenomena
called the tritone Paradox first studied
by Dr Diana Deutsch back in the 80s it's
what scientists call a bistable illusion
which means different people perceive it
in different ways and nobody is right or
wrong
me
Dr Deutsch or Diana as I call her
notice that people in her home country
of England heard these tones differently
than Californians and thus theorized
that the language you hear in infancy
can affect the way you hear these tones
as adults
Rising
[Music]
Rising
me
and falling
[Applause]
you can't lose with a muppet how about
the Muppets
Master of Puppets Jim Harris
thank you very much Kyle for
participating we'll see you later my
friend oh look at that you see how that
went let's see what just happened there
's another surprising connection between
Rhythm and your brain
try to remember the words you hear while
you watch this adorable marsupial have a
snack
here are the things that I bought from
the store lettuce cheese peanut butter
peas apples tortilla chips pizza onion
dip
how many items on the koala's shopping
list can you remember
not many
how about if you hear the same shopping
list from another koala
here are the things that I bought from
the store
lettuce cheese peanut butter peas apples
tortilla chips pizza onion dip
now how many items can you need
chances are you remembered more when the
words were expressed rhythmically our
memory centers the hippocampus and the
frontal cortex process millions of
pieces of information every day
adding a beet serves as a cheat sheet to
help us learn and recall more quickly
which is why most of us learn the
alphabet with a song
next time you head to the market add a
little rhythm to your shopping list so
you don't forget the onion dip so
we're about to have a musical
mind-bending with our own Master
Mentalist lior souchard that's my guy
[Applause]
leorshard has astounded the world with
his amazing powers of suggestion but can
he influence Jack Black's musical mind
I'm so excited you know music affects
our life for good and bad music and all
almost hypnotize us when they influence
us so I would love to do a little gem
session with you yeah the only problem
is yeah
I just see that I just I just wish we
had two guitars to do it oh man if only
we had two guitars available
what's happening
oh have a seat we're gonna do the first
mental gem session so you start and I'll
join all right I'm just gonna go in the
key of D
thank you
brain game
[Music]
is the best games in the world talking
about a brain game
best game in the world
best games
is the best game in the world
[Applause]
don't do it
and not in the budgets
that was fun
that was amazing thank you
we just invented we just invented a song
To You sang brain games brain games
brain games it's the best games in the
world mother loving brain games
best games in the world
now look at me
[Applause]
no because you know when you when we
play together we influence each other
did you feel anything strange while
we're doing this nothing there's a
little electricity I mean look I think
Kyle might be in the in the house and he
might get jealous but uh yeah there was
a chemistry there yeah well if you had
to invent a a title for that song what
would it be you I mean it's just
anything anything something yeah
iguana
I'm going with iguana just because I
think that is the most random thing it
could be iguana pretty random any chance
that somehow through the music and the
tones and the notes I influenced you no
there is no way that you could know that
I was going to say iguana
what you gonna do with that
no
dude
how would for real
for real let's continue playing games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
we all know that certain types of music
can calm us down and help us release
stress but what is it about music that
triggers that reaction in our brains
listen to this piece of music and pay
attention to the sliding scale on your
screen keep track of the number on the
scale at the moment you find the music
to be the most relaxing
[Music]
we'll tell you what the science predicts
you might say when we return
foreign
we asked you to choose the speed at
which the music made you feel the most
relaxed
[Music]
most people start to feel calmest when
the music plays at about 60 beats per
minute when the music is faster our
brain produces beta and gamma waves
causing blood pressure and heart rate to
increase making us feel more awake and
alert when the beats per minute are
lower our brain synchronizes with the
tempo slowing our heart rate and
producing Alpha Waves the brain waves
associated with wakeful relaxation
same piece of music to wildly different
effects on our brain
Bravo
[Applause]
in fact way more than just your mood
please welcome brain games roving
neuroscientist Tara Santa Maria to tell
us more hi good friend
nice to meet you yeah so Cara
tell me what are you up to this week so
this week we fed a bunch of people
chocolate and made them listen to music
for science okay I like that let's see
what happens all right
I've set up a stand in downtown Los
Angeles to test an interesting theory
that music can affect the taste of
chocolate first you've got to wear these
and we're going to start with this
chocolate here my first test subject is
Valerie Gordon one of America's Best
Known chocolatiers
[Music]
okay
so what did the chocolate taste like to
you they're really big coffee notes in
this chocolate okay it's definitely a
high cocoa percent chocolate they're
bitter notes they're coffee notes maybe
more bitter than sweet it's definitely
more bitter than sweet all right well
I'm definitely interested to see how you
feel about the second one right
now I change the music
[Music]
but there's a Twist I gave her the exact
same chocolate
[Music]
so what do you think
I really enjoyed that music while
tasting chocolate
is it good pairing
okay it tastes mellower creamier I think
the music really affected
The Experience though so the music that
you listen to is chocolate was bassier a
little deeper a little darker and this
music was kind of light and Airy and
sweet yes but you were eating the exact
same chocolate oh my God
that's insane Valerie's results were
interesting but now I want to see how
people respond who aren't professional
chocolatiers all right here's the first
one
it's slightly better
your taste is a little is a little
bitter I'm gonna give it a one there we
go I'm gonna give it away yeah with our
first chocolate our volunteers averaged
a 3.3 on the sweetness scale with one
being the most bitter
now let's see what happens when we
change the music
sweet oh
I would say this is a sweeter chocolate
okay a little bit like Fruity bright
fruit you've got a lot of bright fruit
hey guess what they're the same yeah
no
it was the same chocolate what
they're the same chocolate
[Music]
I don't know what's happening in my
brain after several tests the results
remain the same when listening to higher
pitched music our test subjects found
the chocolate to be more than twice as
sweet so when it comes to Chocolate what
you hear might be just as important as
what you taste it is
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
tastes like um
tastes like rock and roll and do you
want to know why it tastes like rock and
roll please I'd love to know why well
there are a ton of studies that show
that our senses in our brain are not as
compartmentalized as we thought there's
a lot of crossover like we can smell
taste and we can hear sight and there's
an extreme example of that called
synesthesia have you heard of that yes I
have I've heard the word but I don't
know what it is it's fascinating it's
when people can literally like smell
words or taste memories and it looks
like we might all just have a little
touch of synesthesia I love it thanks
Kara that's amazing Kara said to Maria
everybody it's fascinating
super fascinating that's good science
that is some delicious science
Tenacious D can entertain us with mind
melting Rock masterpieces but can they
drive us crazy with just a part of a
song let's find out with a little
experiment in something called musical
expectancy
um oh Kyle hey Kyle Gas ladies here we
go
the guy's gonna play a little something
oh say can you
come on girl you're killing me
[Applause]
[Music]
with the help of Jack Black we've been
exploring music's effect on our brain
from enhancing our memory to influencing
our sense of taste and we've seen that
anything can turn into music
earlier we tortured you by having
Tenacious D leave us hanging with this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
oh
oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah
oh that felt good that felt good when
you first heard those chords and they
left us hang in there were you like me
did you just want them to finish the
Star-Spangled Banner yeah well there's
science behind that
music is so rewarding because music is
continually setting up expectations
meeting some of them and not meeting
others music continues to present the
brain with the challenge of figuring out
what will come next it's called musical
expectancy and it takes place in a
region of the brain called brodman area
47.
which is right next to where they keep
the aliens
[Music]
but why does our brain work so hard at
filling in the blanks
it's because our brain is wired to keep
us safe by trying to predict what will
happen next in any situation
like anticipating what might happen when
you take a selfie with an alligator
similar survival mechanism is triggered
when we're listening to music musical
expectancy that's why when we hear Oh
say can you see our brain alerts us that
by the dawn's early light is just around
the corner
[Applause]
oh no
Master Mentalist leorshard is back this
time he's going to make some musical
memories with our audience and Jack oh
look he's also brought some decorative
stemware
so Leo what do you have planned so I try
to prepare something crazy yeah and if
this works I will be in shock as well
okay but we need everybody for this so
guys are you ready over there you guys
ready
all right
for that I'll be the Mind conductor yes
you're gonna need the entire audience to
repeat after me so you go first please
repeat after me tada
[Music]
okay this side now decide now you ready
you you
and you come over here standing one line
over here and from here I was looking at
you
I was looking at you
you are great for this stand up you
and you are great you are great come
over here give them also we're gonna
play stand there behind them quickly
stand right here
okay we've got over 50 glassware over
here each one of you and the third are
going to go here select the glass and
put it over there okay on that table
over there are you ready go take a glass
take a glass
mm-hmm perfect go ahead select the glass
come over here stand here all different
variety of glasses big small this one
pour it over there wait
select the glass
nice nice good selection good selections
good selections good selections any
glass okay don't drink of it Mason
Ry
the other dude got to correct
it's amazing because they have no idea
what they're doing
oh she didn't seemed like she knew what
she was doing oh yeah
over there huh put it over there come
here come here come here come here
the anchor okay oh okay we got it give
them a big round of applause so
eight random people eight random glasses
no Keegan yes Jack leior and you know
you know the feeling when you have you
hear a song in the radio yep and it's
just in your brain it's in your brain
and it keeps going again and again and
again it's like stuck to your mind can
you think of a song like that got it you
got it it stuck to your brain I got it
can you sing it in your mind but be
careful not to let it um
haha
yeah that's the best lick
kill it Jack shred it okay you can stop
so it's like the song gets stuck to your
right yeah you just hold it without
looking without looking hold it without
looking without looking without looking
without looking without looking a song
that stuck to your mind
what was the song that stuck to your
mind
[Music]
what's the name of the American Pie
American pieces
oh
dude
American Pie
I don't come on man yeah you know what's
crazier what's crazy there's a little
secret hit in here you know I was
telling you about I'm the Mind conductor
yes sir well this is not the conductor's
Baton it is the musician's mullet
oh the mallets I have over 50 glasses
here each one gives different sound
different tune filled with water not
filled with water each one is different
eight people selected from the audience
randomly they didn't even know which
glass they will take literally billions
of possible combinations billions of
billions come with me come with me stand
over here wait a second oh my God you go
there Jack Jack I'm Gonna Let You Get Up
In It Get Up In It Jack remind me the
song again American Pie
man miss American Pie
you took any glass literally any glass
you want
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
how do you do that
oh my God I understand
you do it
cause now we're singing
American Pie
amazing dude unbelievable amazing that's
unbelievable
now it's my turn to amaze you check out
this video unbelievable we've all had
the experience of mishearing certain
lyrics while listening to a song this
phenomenon is called Amanda green
and it's caused by our brain
misinterpreting sounds either because
they're unclear or because we are
unconsciously expecting to hear
something else
listen to this audio clip created by Dr
Diana Deutsch
do you hear any particular word or
phrase nowhere nowhere nowhere nowhere
nowhere nowhere
nowhere where nowhere nowhere I'll tell
you what it all means after this
[Applause]
before the break we played this audio
clip nowhere nowhere nowhere nowhere
nowhere nowhere nowhere and asked if you
perceived any particular word or phrase
did you hear any of these words
you're not alone the dude is something
called peridolia our brain's tendency to
try to find patterns and meaning in
everything
it's the auditory equivalent of seeing a
face in a cloud or a religious figure in
a piece of toast doctors once thought
paradolia was a symptom of psychosis but
today we know it's perfectly normal it's
just our brains attempt to inject a
little sense into a chaotic World
nowhere nowhere nowhere nowhere nowhere
[Applause]
[Music]
we are talking music in our brains with
Jack Black
so Jack um a lot of studies and research
have shown that uh the music that we
listen to when we're teenagers kind of
stays with us and resonates with us do
you have any anecdotes or stories about
music in your teenage years well when I
think if I'm a teenage years I think
about a lot of heavy metal uh-oh I had
like a a strange mix eclectic mix of
Music yes because I I loved like uh Ozzy
Osbourne Black Sabbath yeah but then I
also loved like uh Bobby McFerrin and uh
in high school I did a lot of musical
theater uh did you yeah I was a museum
you know I was a theater
dudes and I did I was Pippin in a
production of Pippin you played in
Pippin no less I was Pippin and Pippin
yes is one of my proudest moments I had
to drop a couple lbs I had to stop
eating a bean and cheese burritos Focus
just on like tuna and some boring celery
and again then I got into pip and shape
yeah and dude I was looking good
ah
so from infancy it seems like our brains
are conditioned to respond to music and
sometimes we just can't help moving to
the beat
[Music]
why is dancing so infectious
long ago the ability to dance was
connected to the ability to survive
according to a 2006 study dancing was a
way for our early ancestors to bond and
communicate particularly during hard
times as a result early humans who were
coordinated in rhythmic had better
survival rates
now our love and aptitude for dancing
contributes to a higher brain
functioning and a rise in serotonin
levels which in turn makes us more
physically and socially connected and
generally better at Living a happy life
so dance on
[Music]
yeah yeah you're comfortable Jack I feel
like Hannibal Lecter yeah
[Music]
Jack Black is clearly in tune with his
insightful and musical brain we're about
to put that perceptive brain to the test
in the gauntlets
oh yeah oh yeah
each week our celebrity guests play the
same series of games designed to test
their balance perception and focus
and Jack Black Master our mental
minefield
[Music]
dangerous because it is
please you will start you have 15
seconds to get as much water as you
possibly can into that glass ready and
go
here we go
foreign
[Applause]
I felt more like Tommy Lee actually
let's go over here to station two my
friend
station two all about perception now
what I want you to do is watch these
three super short videos and simply tell
me what you hear okay okay
Bill's kind of burly
Bill's kind of girly now that is
incorrect next video
I made you batter
I made you fatter
incorrect next video
the fat is there
the bat is bare
incorrect incorrect okay well that's a
tough one it's tough
it is not easy right here my friend
station three I made you fatter
station three's intuition it is you
against lior in three games of rock
paper scissors okay you only have to
beat him one time okay round one okay go
one two three go it's high he's going
close that's good that's good that's
good round two go one two three go oh
another tie gotta beat him once round
second is too good for this one second
okay
let me think of what you're thinking
that I'm going through I'm ready ready
I'm ready one two three go
he's the best that is very good Leon
but you on the triple tie we've never
had a triple tie before several times
we've never had it I'll take it
now we're doing mental processing you're
gonna match the color of the letters on
the ball with the name of the color on
the bin and at some point you're going
to hear this
that means that the names will change on
the bin those letters are black black
here we go over here my friend the color
of the letters on the ball goes into the
words on the beach that's right there
you go the second I hand this you got 30
seconds on the clock to knock it down
you ready yes and go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the beams have changed
[Applause]
five four
three two one time's up
very good that was good right
final station maintaining composure
you're just gonna hold this tray right
here
that the ladies are going to provide for
you in your dominant hands and you're
just going to balance these cups right
here that's all you're doing balancing
the cups maintain your composure bounce
the cups keep your cool that's all you
got to do is just stand there look
forward keep your cool that's all you
got to do
they look a little trembly
[Applause]
oh my God
me and I knew it was coming
he got you with the tubes you got me
with a tube
oh my God what if I would have died
though
let's take a look at this some replay a
little bit of Replay right here oh we
got a tube
oh God
oh that my man my man went like this
after YouTube
um how was that whole experience for you
I mean it was challenging the the
reading of the lips was insanely hard I
can't believe I got it wrong so every
time it's really tough the mcgurk effect
which is how what you see can affect
what you hear I made you better his
mouth is saying one thing and the words
are another thing the trick would have
been to use the force and close my eyes
and just just listen to the dude right
but yeah exactly then you played rock
paper scissors against lior which
resulted in zilch but you are our first
triple Tire we've never had a triple
Tire before so and is there an exercise
that you felt you felt like you were
more akin to uh well obviously the balls
with the colors yeah I'm very good with
colored balls
thank you
you got eight of those correct
yes
finally
many of us find it easy to identify a
video when it's played backwards but
when you play music or speech backwards
we have a hard time making heads or
tails of it like this song
that's my dance that's my backward dance
I think that was uh Mrs Satan Mrs Satan
the name of that song is Mrs Satan
backwards
I don't know who it is he does not know
you do not know okay we're gonna find
out in a minute we're going to find out
in a second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes okay did you figure out the song
that we were playing backward let's hear
it again
okay there it is well let's turn that
beat around huh
[Applause]
no trouble I'm all about that baby
[Applause]
how are you
yes
Meghan Trainor ladies and gentlemen
thank you thank you thank you thank you
everyone bye yes Jack Black and Meghan
Trainor today
what are we even doing
unexpected combo
Megan
thank you so much for being here thank
you super jazzed would you be up for
playing a game with Mr Jack Black
yeah okay all right all right I'm here
so now this is an experiment in musical
improvisation according to Dr Daniel
Levinson of McGill University to be a
great improviser you need to activate
the networks in your brain responsible
for daydreaming and deactivate the ones
for self-criticism good improvisers rely
on a highly active pre-motor area which
coordinates movement and language
basically your brain says goodbye
inhibitions and goes with the flow does
it feel that way to you Chuck yeah in
fact I know Dr Dan Leviton of McGill
University and I think he's totally
right
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my God
[Applause]
now I know the guy
now
you know him
now you know
you know now you know Dr Daniel Levinson
from McGill University also known as Dr
improv apparently exactly yeah
[Applause]
here's how this is going to work Megan
and Jack will sing the Disco classic I
Will Survive love it yes yep yep Megan
is going to sing the first line the way
it's written and then Jack will have to
improvise a new line with a rhyming word
that we give him and he needs to do this
while keeping up with the beat you're
gonna have to riff it in okay
Betsy Ross sell that flag weave it in
there okay all right you ready you got
this hold on let me turn off the
individuals
let her
[Music]
[Applause]
ripe
you know I was eating chicken and I like
deep fried
[Music]
my favorite sparkly flowers
[Music]
it's free
[Music]
I'm going hunting now yes I'm hunting
wild boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I Will Survive
[Music]
[Applause]
Jack Black and Meghan Trainor Kyle Gas
what do we learn tonight
babies listening to music are adorable
Jack Black is really good at Improv
and uh and music can make chocolate
taste better uh it's amazing okay let's
sing this song out y'all come on hey
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]